وقبل اقل من ساعه من الان تبنت الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده باغلبيه مئه وواحد
واربعين صوتا قرارا يجدد مطالبه روسيا بان
تسحب فورا وبشكل كامل ودون اي شرط جميع
قواتها العسكريه من اراضي اوكرانيا
ويدعو الى وقف الاعمال العدائيه القرار
المقدم من اوكرانيا يشدد على ضروره التوصل
في اقرب وقت ممكن الى سلام شامل وعادل
ودائم في اوكرانيا بما يتفق ومبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده كما اعاد القرار التاكيد
على التزام الجمعيه العامه بسياده
اوكرانيا واستقلالها ووحدتها وسلامتها
الاقليميه داخل حدودها المعترف بها دوليا
يشدد القرار الامامي ايضا على ضروره ضمان
المساءله عن الجرائم الاشد خطوره وفق
تصنيف القانون الدولي
المرتكبه على اراضي اوكرانيا وذلك من خلال
تحقيقات ومحاكمات تكون مناسبه وعادله
ومستقله
ومن مقر الامم المتحده في نيويورك ينضم
الينا الان مراسلنا مراد هاشم مراد حدثنا
عن ما جرى في جلسه التصويت وما الذي يعني
التوصل الى هذا القرار
نعم الليله اغلبيه ساحقه اغلبيه الثلثين
صوتت لصالح هذا القرار الذي قدمته
اوكرانيا
ورعته اكثر من سبعين دوله وصوتت لصالحه
141 دوله اظهر بالفعل كما ارادت الدول
الغربيه روسيا معزوله داخل الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده الا من دعم ست دول
رفضت هذا القرار الى جانب روسيا وهي
بيلاروسيه
المالي
نيكاراغوا سوريا كوريا الشماليه ارتيريا
لكن هناك دول مهمه ايضا تحفظت على هذا
القرار وعلى راسها الصين والهند
وجنوب افريقيا وايران وباكستان والجزائر
وعدد كبير من الدول الافريقيه
بطبيعه الحال هذا القرار ما يميزه عن جمله
القرارات التي اعتمدتها الجميع العامه منذ
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا انه اكثر قرارات
التي تضمنت
مواد تتعلق بالسلام وتدعو للسلام وتدعم
الحل السلمي وذلك في محاوله لجلب اكبر عدد
من الاصوات وهو ما تحقق اذ كان الهاجس
هاجس الداعمين لهذا القرار ان يكون هناك
عدد اقل من الاصوات مقارنه بما حصلت عليه
القرارات السابقه وبالتالي ما يرسل رسائل
تشجيع لروسيا وهو ما لم يحدث روسيا مع ذلك
رات ان هذه المضامين تعكس بطبيعه الحال خ
الدول الغربيه من انها بالفعل بدات تفقد
بعض التاييد العالمي وهي دعمت التعديلات
التي انت قدمت بها بيلاروسيا والتي كانت
تحذف الدعوه الى سحب روسيا لقواتها وكذلك
انهاء الحرب
وتدعو الى مفاوضات لحل السلمي وكذلك الى
وقفه ارسال الاسلحه الى من قبل الاطراف
الثالثه الى مناطق القتال وهي تعديلات لم
تحصل على التاييد الكافي داخل القاعه
بطبيعه الحال هذه الجلسه هي الجلسه
الاستثنائيه الطارئه الحادي عشر واستانفت
في ذكرى مرور عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
ليلا وبلا شك سنتابع تداعيات نتائج هذا
التصويت اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات مراد
هاشم من نيويورك